10 time all-star World Series champion
and MVP of the National League 2-time
NLCS mm NLCS MVP for time Gold Glove
Award winner and the man who holds the
record for most consecutive games played
in the Senior Circuit care of our
friends at King's Hawaiian good Seaview
Steve gari how long don't I know if you
notice as a as a Wolverine unless that
was right as a Wolverine I did leave out
your uh your collegiate experience you
were welcome I am a Wolverine
that was my backup school you need a
Michigan man you reach for that category
right how did you get to Michigan State
you're from Florida orange Tampa Florida
and played football baseball right and I
had about 20 offers there's a beginning
of specialization so I had football
Florida Miami baseball Florida State
right albarn football but I want to play
two sports and our pitching coach should
at amber Chamberlain high school had
played for Danny let Wyler who was the
Michigan State baseball coach right but
at Bennett Florida State so he says
Danny we got this kid he might might
just come up there if you get him up and
schmooze him and everything so he took a
bus my dad grow four Greyhound mom and I
went up and Danny medicine took us to
Jennison Fieldhouse and I was showing
this this trophy's and all of a sudden
this man comes around the corner and
it's the great Irishman Duffy Doherty
and he comes up and he said some here
you play two sports and I said yes sir I
do he said well he said once you play a
little football for his to and you know
maybe well both ways he said we got
twenty three thousand coeds and he'd
bound to get a date on Friday night I
wasn't doing too bad but you know I need
all the help I can get and went out and
at that time you know they were a little
depleted and defensive back I was a
quarterback and by the second week I was
starting right corner and
played against Michigan and a big USC
when AJ Simpson was there his first year
67 so did you ever think of
professionally pursuing that yeah but I
was you know there's no big demand for a
slow corner so so what was afforded so I
would have been a weak safety maybe
because I understood the game quartet
mentality and when I first started I
played some defense in high school so
you know i intercepted a few passes in
the first scrimmage you know and that's
it no more quarterback for me but it
worked well love playing Big Ten
football played it at Notre Dame that it
was a wonderful I always said playing
two sports gives you a great balance and
understanding hey Kurt Warner says it
all the time and a bunch of the guys
that I work with at the NFL Network say
it all the time that football coaches
should not discourage players from
playing baseball
also Deion I mean Deion sure talks about
it all the time how crucial his baseball
playing experience was in helping him as
an athlete he talks about baseball all
the time that will tell you that one
compliments the other you know baseball
obviously more eye hand coordination but
balance and and and quickness and being
able to sit for a long time and having
to concentrate without anything
happening reacting right away right you
know football you got 11 guys
continuously going each other baseball
is only 7 minutes of action in the game
so you really have to focus and
concentrate and watch so it's a great
balance Steve Garvey here on the Rich
Eisen show and we were talking off air
cuz Al Michaels been on this show many
many times talking about how he was an
announcer he would tell me a story was
an announcer in Hawaii calling calling
some minor league games and Lasorda
Lasorda suggested that the Dodgers look
at al to call games because and I asked
Alan like how did Lasorda know how you
call a game if he's in the game and he
said well the sorta got thrown out
before a game started because he was
still arguing from the night before
right once a week no matter what
and so was Lasorda you're your manager
Spokane triple-a I love the coast league
and I was up and down in 70 but that
team was a phenomenal team it's been
picked several times is the greatest
minor-league team in history but 11 guys
they think that played each of us played
over 10 years in the majors which is
phenomenal so were you all on it Lopes
and say and were you all on it to
Valentine and Paciorek and Tommy Hutton
who went on to go with the Phillies huh
Steve soggy was a catcher for us but he
quarterbacked at SC electic but a great
group of guys won the division by 28 but
we play the Hawaii Islanders 28 games
our division and and the first one and
and I hadn't actually heard al over
there but there in the first game the
old Spokane Stadium it's wouldn't it
echoes in this poisonous my gosh the
Dodgers as Scully to come up and call a
few games for us well was it Scully it
was out and he sounded just like them so
the first night I hit a home run win the
game after we do the postgame interview
in the dugout and Al and I were talking
in it I was amazed and how he had the
diction down and and then down pat now
of course we all knew the evolution
after that was the great calls and the
great career he's sure but but to see
him when we both were but both were in
triple-a yeah and we'll be able to go on
from there and of course he's been a
dear friend and we seem it to scout of
the great restaurants the ASAP you can't
forget can't forget Linda Steve Garvey
here on the Rich Eisen show so your
first all-star game you are write in
candidate correct were you the Ryan 74
I'm a wild arm third baseman early in 73
no big demand for that but I'm
pinch-hitting and all of a sudden I'm
leading the National League and it's
June 23rd 73 I get a pinch hit in the
eighth inning against the Reds lefties
were killing us we lose one of only two
hits I'm sitting in my locker Walter
Alston comes by and he looks at me said
you ever play first I said absolutely
played one game in Little League and one
in triple spokane was in the first base
that I got yeah
and he said get a glove start tonight
and don't trip over the bag and Doug
went out of the dirt came off made a tag
two doubles two RBIs and I'm sitting
there after the game and you know these
days where everything comes together
we've worked hard or out of nowhere a
blessing is hit you I'm sitting there
and how the corner of my eye comes
through the tunnel at Dodger Stadium and
he walks by doesn't stop and I hear
you're in a tomorrow and Steve Yeager's
next to me and we look at each other I
says he's talking to you he says no I
think he's talking to you go and and
that was the beginning that night was
the beginning of say Lopes Russell and
Garvey that began eight and a half years
and the beginning of my career and I do
a lot of motivational speaking and I
talk about moments in our life when
you're asked to do something that you
haven't done if and if you're a little
suspect or you're a little afraid to
take the jump don't do it simplify
just beige 'vu whatever it is take it
make the effort to do it and if I had
said no I've never played first probably
wouldn't be here today but carpe diem
seize the moment and went out that night
and gave it my darkness and found out
and my height at five ten I can pick the
ball out of there pretty well you could
see Russell used to yell at me garv get
off your knees and they'd sing I'm
saving you you know all that stuff Steve
way bit high yeah you know throw it high
wave goodbye throw it low we're good to
go with garbs unless I guess Reggie
Jackson is throwing his hip out during
the World Series remember that one
flagrant for the rest of the season
didn't need to take steroids back end he
just did something that and and we end
up losing that game yes the time run
scores and I finally got him to admit it
that I call the way we were to where I
do one-on-ones with you know former
players and arenas and so forth
yeah and finally last year I said let's
just admit we have four people you and
Reggie Sam Atwell casino in LA and and
it's it's time now he gave me that sweet
little smile yeah I did it I said speak
louder cheering laughing is he's in LA
in the shadows
Sadie I said okay now let's recreate it
and he got up and he actually showed how
he stuck the hip at that was a big play
I mean that's huge sort of went nuts
right didn't he go crazy oh yeah because
Frank pulleys in part first and his
credit he's at the line looking this way
Reggie's in front of me stopped and he
sticks out his hip from a ball coming
that way and I go to reach it's gone and
I always send them looking around they
see the ball bounce over towards the
dugout and I get it by that time I've
gone to third now everything breaks
loose so assorted comes out and was sort
of would give one of the heats you know
and then the minor-league desi was
thrown out every week because he chewed
tobacco and those poor umpires were
covered with tobacco oh don't think
about it too long now it's lunch hours
somewhere but so he's arguing I saw
Ocoee way second Frank didn't see it I
understand shadow but the second base
umpire the American league umpire had to
have seen it because it was a short
liner to second Billy Russell short
hopped it stepped on the bag throws to
me well I go over there and he looks at
me as if didn't say a thing and I'm
saying you had to have seen it I know
he's thinking I've got to come back to
Yankee Stadium there's no way I'm gonna
call this and then you see a replay if
you ever see the game and you see the
umpire look at the bag that rustle and
look at first base and you know he's
seen Reggie stick out the hip but never
called me Steve Garvey here on the
Richmond showing I only have a few
minutes left with you hear about one
thing I do want to hit you what was it
like being in the Los Angeles mid 70s
all those games going on you know the
celebrities that were beefs going
through some it was not sure going
through once Tommy I mean it was it was
it was really special and then Lasorda
came and it was a whole new level of
Hollywood and celebrity and Danny Kaye
would come in with his little slippers
and do a dance and and Rickles would
come by and and he would say something
about each guy and make you belly laugh
and you get to me and he says I can't
say anything you you're my son's
favorite player
but I want to say one thing yeah you
step out of the shower to take a don't
you and everybody would laugh I said yes
I did and but that was rock'n'roll quick
Sinatra said he will do the national
anthem for Lasorda Fiero became manager
an opening day so he comes puts a jacket
jaunty hat goes to centerfield starts up
O's forgets the third stanza shortest
national anthem of all time Burt Hooton
sex demean he says Lasorda white Burton
the heck is that guy just miss the next
two-term students thank you starts city
Frank Sinatra yeah oh it sounded good
for two-thirds of the nationally and you
are here again we'll talk about Kings
wine in a second on home run to every
day you took part in the first first one
home run derby was in 1985 in the meadow
in the Metrodome or you know you take
heavier workouts and at that time fans
were allowed to come in which was great
mhm
and the PR fella for the twins comes
over and says mr. B we went a little
extemporaneous Home Run Derby dude I
said sure so it was Murphy and Parker
and myself and I think it was George
Brett two other guys we each got ten
pitches Wow and I think I hit a couple
out Parker at 3 and that was the
beginning of arguably this great
property on ESPN that make it as good a
numbers as the game on Tuesday do you
understand why some guys don't want to
do it cuz they think it prolongs a
select judge got into a slump last year
some guys are afraid of solutely but a
sense to you back when I was playing
right we attack the ball at a different
angle we want to hit line drives
backspin so forth
now it's about launch angle its lured a
high the home runs the the single most
important element of offense now so guys
have a different angle approaching the
ball strikeouts don't matter anymore
right I mean I average 60 something
strikeouts one here at 90 and I was in I
was depressed because at 90 but the sort
of wanted home runs and I hit him so it
can put you in a deep slumber the way
the guy that that leads the first round
ever wins music
himself out but a lot of these guys have
a launch angle just naturally so go
ahead and do it you know then it would
have thrown me into a slump or anybody
that tried it so I know all about kings
of wine because my kids love it we we
have in our house what was staple great
American comes great right our family
came over 60 years ago and they had a
little bakery in in Hawaii and decided
let's try it and in the States and and
it's been a staple ever since now we've
expanded with our food line on food
lines to barbecue sauces so Eric Dickens
senior VP of Marketing at King's
Hawaiian a year ago said hey what can we
do with this and I said let's take it in
stadiums and arenas let's create let's
capture summer mm-hmm and we put
together the Kings who are on grill at
Dodger Stadium epicenter of food because
we've got pulled pork and sliders and
tried tips so good now we've got this
roll Yankee Stadium heard about it we're
in their Fenway Park's did a kiosk
earlier this year they're creating space
and we're talking with Wrigley now so
Brett Connick product and iconic
stadiums with great American food
yeah King's Hawaiian calm you can go
follow him on Twitter at King's Hawaiian
and use the hashtag King's Hawaiian
Aloha hour as well before I let you go I
do have to ask about one more guy a
homerun Derby one of the last home run
derby I covered for ESPN one of the
analysts was Tony Gwynn one of the
nicest human being oh absolutely I have
ever come across and obviously you're
known as a Dodger but you play so I
cross the five and Camp Pendleton line
and went down got to play with
absolutely with Tony Ryall five years it
was a second year when I got there and a
little something about I'm I'm in the
back clubhouse of this dressing area in
new marathon at 7:00 in the morning and
nobody's there and I'm jumping rope
because I'm 34 and I know yeah I'm on a
clock and I better keep getting myself
ready in this low lights and I'm I feel
somebody's in there and I turn around
there's Tony he's a guard what are you
doing
I said I'm buying time
and he looked at me smiled he said am I
gonna have to do that I said eventually
mm-hmm I said because you're you're
blessed and honored to play this game
every minute of every day take the
opportunity to play as long as you
possibly can because this only comes
around once and and he got it he
understood it that's why when you saw
Tony play he never gave you less than a
hundred percent and for me to be with
him those five years was a blessing for
me because we talked about the nuances
of the game and I think I maybe have
said one or two things that had helped
him that for me that's that's part of
this fraternity of giving back of us men
who have been blessed to play it he
played 20 years played 20 yeah and you
sir I know you were Southern California
based please let me know when you're in
Los Angeles I'd love to have you on in
my show studio there too and my
wonderful daughter Olivia Garvey works
for NFL and Los Angeles she says she's
oh she works on the registry looks like
her mother yeah it works on the red zone
okay which doesn't injustice - how
pretty she is okay but it's a she's
loving it by the way it's and she
listens and she learns from you oh and
they're all ready no listen no no it's
face you she's a little heavy in
baseball no no hold on a second I just
want to make sure that her work
environment is good she doesn't learn
for me she learns from Scott Hanson the
host of red zone by the way that's his
full name Scott Hanson host of red zone
slip the meals underneath you no good to
see you great to be waited to see you
okay that's Steve Garvey here follow him
on Twitter at Steve Garvey 6:00 we're
gonna take a break come back sneak in a
quick phone call or check on our poll
question and then Pedro Martinez shows
up here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience